a team of six unlikely friends coming
together to solve problems and make the
world a better place
kinda they are the big maker six
hey that's our car
there's a ninja stealing change out of
our car Oh somebody help there's an
interchange car a ninja sending the team
right now stealing pennies from people's
cars eh well my friends and I are here
to change your mind
get it ninja he said change yeah cuz you
were stealing change
you
hi guys I got this
we got the ninja ask why such a meanie
stealing from other people's tariffs
yeah god yeah ninja why are you so mean
I don't know I mean I'm not a bad guy
listen Angelica can I call you ninja you
can never give up ninja I know it gets
hard sometimes but life is funny like
that ninja yeah ninja what makes you
happy
I like building robots well let's get
that mask off so you don't look so scary
oh those cheekbones are to die for yeah
you know we can help you make robots
we're a team of geniuses
thanks to Disney Animation for
partnering with me on this video check
out big hero 6 in theaters November 7th
and click here for more fun big hero 6
videos we made together